قال مسؤولون اتراك ان الجيش بلادهم لا
يحتاجوا الا لايام قليله ليكون جاهزا
لعمليه توهل بري في شمال سوريا ومن الامر
ينتظر قرارا سياسيا وفيما تستمر القوات
التركيه في قصف مواقع لفصائل الكرديه
مسلحه قالت موسكو التي تتحفظ بشده هي
واشنطن على العمليه انها تتواصل مع انقره
بشان الخلافات المتعلقه بها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسرات ما العوامل التي تحسم
مضيه تركيه قدما في عمليتها العسكريه
المحتمله شماليه سوريا وكيف توازن بين
التنسيقها مع واشنطن وموسكو وبين اتخاذها
هذا القرار اي ثمن استراتيجيا منتظر لهذه
العمليه المزرعه وكيف ستتعامل انقره مع
الانعكاسات المحتمله لهذه العمليه على
تنسيقها مع روسيا واشنطن في ملف سوريا
ذلك ما التفهمات والتوازنات الحاكمه
للاتصالات الروسيه التركيه والتركيه
الامريكيه بشان هذه العمليه خاصه مع حديثي
موسكو واشنطن عن خلاف مع تركيا بهذا الصدد
[موسيقى]
تبدو تركيا عقيده عزمها علشان هي عمليه
توغل بريه في الشمال السوري القصف المدفعي
والغارات الجويه المستمره منذ اسبوع لا
تكفي فيما يبدو والتحفظات الروسيه لا
تثنيها عن المضيق قدما يحتاج الامر قرارا
سياسيا وترقبا لما قد تقود اليه اتصالات
الروسيه مع انقره بشان اختلاف وجهات النظر
بشان العمليه البريه الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان قال ان بلاده مصممه على شتاء
في حزب العمال الكردستاني من جذوره داعيا
لانهاء ما وصفهه بلعبه دعم حزب العمال
الكردستاني وامتداداته التي تتخفى تحت
الستار مكافحه تنظيم الدوله
انجي كافته
في الاسبوع الماضي بينهم ثلاثه اطفال وذلك
في شارع الاستقلال في اسطنبول ومن بعده في
ناحيه كركميز في تركيا
مسؤوليته دماء هؤلاء ضحايا تقع على هذه
المنظمه الانفصاليه والدول التي تدعمها
بالسلاح والعتاد باسم محاربه داعش التي من
الواضح انها مزروعه في منطقتنا تركيا التي
حاربت تنظيم الدوله على الارض وجها لوجه
وهزمته لن تقبل بتبريرات كهذه تنظيم حزب
العمال الارهابي ليس تحديدا لوحده التراب
التركي بل انه تهديد لوحده التراب السوري
والعراقي ايضا ونحن مصممون على اجتزات هذه
المنظمه الارهابيه من الجذورها فولدوا
بلانات في المقابله قالت الرئيسه المشتركه
لما يعرف بمكتب الدفاع في الاداره الذاتيه
لشمال والشرق سوريا بيان العلي قالت ان
الرده سيكون قاسيا اذا ما استمرت الهجمات
التركيه وطلبت العاليه الدولتين الضامتين
لوقف اطلاق النار الولايات المتحده وروسيا
بتحديد موقف واضح من هذه الهجمات وباي ان
يتحمل المجتمع الدولي مسؤولياته تجاه
الاداره الذاتيه وما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه بحسب قولها
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من موسكو
السفير اندريه
نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس من
واشنطن الدكتور الانفسكي كبير الباحثين في
قضايا الامن القوميه الامريكي من اسطنبول
الدكتور طارق غزلو عميد كليه العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه ايضا في اسطنبول اهلا
بكم جميعا الى ما وراء الخبر ابدا معك سيد
طارق اذا الجيش التركي جاهز ولا ينتظر سوى
القرار السياسي ما هي الاعتبارات التي
تحدد ان يتجه بالفعل الى عمليه بريه ام لا
عشان
يشتركين
الحكومه التركيه سوف تنظم عمليه عسكريه في
الاجزاء الشماليه من البلاد في القريب
العاجل منذ منذ 10 دقائق اعلن الرئيس
التركي ان الحكومه اخذت كل الاعتبارات
بعين الاعتبار بما في ذلك الرد في المنطقه
من قبل البلدان الاخرى والرئيس اردوغان
اعرب عن عزمي تركيا على البدء بهذه
العمليه بغض النظر عن التاثيرات
والديناميات المختلفه حول العلاقه بين
تركيا والدول الاخرى وبالتالي اوضح الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان تركيا سوف تضع
حدا للاعمال الارهابيه التي تاتي عبر
الحدود الشماليه باتجاه تركيا هذه هي
النقطه الاساسيه التي شدد عليها في خطابه
وبعد مناقشات واسعه النطاق على مستوى
الوزاريه التركي
ان القرار السياسي لم يتخذ بالضروره بعد
هل هذا دقيق
طيب اذا تفضل نعم القرار السياسي لم يتخذ
بعد ولكن على الارجح في الايام القليله
المقبله القياده التركيه سوف تعطي الضوء
الاخضر من خلال قرار سياسي لهذه العمليه
العسكريه هذه الرساله التي استخلصتها من
الخطاب الذي ادلى به الرئيس التركي بعد
المداولات على المستوى الوزاري التركي
السيد
رجب طيب اردوغان لم يتخذ القرار بعد هو
بلا شك حريص على الموقف الروسي
ولكن لم ياتي الرد الرافض بشكل قاطع او
يمكن القول من ملاحظات التصريحات التي
ادلت بها موسكو حتى الان
تحفظ ولكن ليس رفا كاملا
يقترب الى تفهم المقاربه التركيه هل توافق
الموقف الروسي
نحن بكل تاكيد ضد هذه العمليات من قبل
تركيا نحن نعتقد ان الرئيس التركي
الان عندما تكون روسيا ملتهيه بالمعارك في
اوكرانيا وامريكا منتهيه بروسيا والصين هو
يستخدم هذه الظروف حتى يحقق
خطه كان طويله الامل منذ سنوات حتى يقوم
بصدد او السيطره على حوالي 8000 كم مربع
من الاراضي
الروسيه والسيطره عليها تماما
بمبرر
النوايا الارهابيه عند التشكيلات الموجوده
في تلك الاراضي
بالطبع العمليات الارهابيه موجوده في ارض
الواقع ولكن ليس هناك اي معلومات انها
تحدث من اراضي السوريه واذا كان هكذا اذا
هذه حالات خاصه جدا قد تكون قد نظمت من
المقاومه السياسيه التركيه من الصعب الغاء
هذا الاحتمال لذلك يجب ان تكون روسيا ضد
هذه العمليه العسكريه بالنسبه للاراضي
المنتميه لدوله مستقله اخرى
ماذا عن الولايات المتحده السيد همم السيد
اعلن مقفصي في النهايه واشنط لديها وجود
على الارض وهي ايضا همم لا ننسى انها
تتحالف مع جماعات كرديه مسلحه فكيف يمكن
وصف درجه احتجاج واشنطن
ورفضها لمثل هذا التحرك التركي
مساء الخير لك ولي المشاهدين الكرام اعتقد
انها من بين الظروف التي نادره ما تحصل
والتي نرى فيها ان الولايات المتحده
وروسيا لديهما مواقف مشابهه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه شانها شان روسيا لا تود
ان ترى تركيا تشن عمليه في الاراضي
السوريه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ترى
في المقام الاول انا من شان ذلك ان يشتت
الانتباه والتركيز عن القتال ضد داعش هناك
الالاف من المقاتلين التابعين لتنظيم
الدوله الذين لا يزلونه في سوريا وقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه الميليشيا الكرديه كانت
او بقياده كرديه كانت تقاتل ضد تنظيم
الدوله بالتعاون مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهناك قلق امريكي بان الوضع في
سوريا يمكن ان يصبح اقل استقرارا وتركيا
بالمناسبه تحتل حوالي 400.000 مربع في ااا
سوريا وتقريبا نتحدث عن اراضي بحجم لبنان
وبالتالي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا
تود ان ترى توسعا للوجود التركي ولكن
الولايات المتحده سوف تتعاون مع تركيا لكي
تحاول ان تبقي على وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه خارج هذه المنطقه وهي 30 كيلو متر
جنوب الحدود مع تركيا
على العموم المواقف التركيه ما زالت يعني
تتوالى خلينا نستمع الى اخر ما قاله
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الذي قال
في واحد من اخر تصريحاته مشيرا الى
المواقف الدوليه من العمليه البريه التي
ينوي الجيش التركي القيام بها في شمال
السوري قال لن نحصل على اذن من احد
لمحاربه التنظيمات الارهابيه اذا
الرئيس التركي لا ينتظر موافقه ولا مباركه
ولا اذن من اي جهه فيما اذا قرر والسؤال
هنا للسيد اندرياس اذا وقرر فعلا المضيف
في هذه الخطوه ما هي الانعكاسات المحتله
من وجهه نظر روسيا
يعني وميرن
في الاوضاع الحاليه
ضد القوات التي سوف تجتاح اراضي سوريا
ولكن اننا سوف نساعد الشعب المسلح السوري
هذا شيء اكيد نحن نعتقد ان افعال السيد
اردوغان غير مبرره وهي اجتياحيه احتلاليه
ونحن اسفين ان الاوضاع الحاليه للعلاقات
بين روسيا وامريكا هي عقبه للجميع لتوحيد
الجهود حتى نقف ضد هذه العمليه الغير
قانونيه من قبل انقره انا كنت مشترك شخصيا
في المفاوضات بين روسيا
وامريكا والكثير من المواقف هي واحده علما
ان الاسباب لدينا ولد الامريكان مختلف
وهناك نظره سلبيه همم التصرفات في تركيا
توافق على ما يقوله ضيفنا من موسكو وخصوصا
وان الرئيس التركي يقولها صراحه لا ننتظر
اذنا من احد ماذا تقرا في ثنايا ما يقوله
الرئيس
يتحدث عن
التنفيذ هذه يخطط لهذه العمليه منذ الربيع
الماضي سوف نرى ما اذا كان سوف ينفذ هذه
العمليه في هذه المره عندما قام بالتخطيط
للعمليه الاخيره في اكتوبر 2019 الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فرضت عقدات على تركيا
وكانت انا ذاك برئاسه ترامب واستمرت
العقوبات حتى
وافقت تركيا على
وقف اطلاق النار بعد ايام انا انا موقف
الرئيس اردوغان انه ينظر الى الموقف الجيو
السياسي في المنطقه ويرى ان الوضع يختلف
روسيا بحاجه الى تركيا في مستوى اكبر
بكثير بالمقارنه مع 2019 حيث ان تركيا
تركيا عبور
الاقتصاديه نحو العالم حيث ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي لديه عقوبات على
المتحده الامريكيه ترى تركيا مهمه كذلك
واشنطن كذلك ترى تركيا على انها مهمه
للغايه حيث ان تركيا هي حليفه الولايات
المتحده 52 في خلف شمال الاطلسي وتود
الولايات المتحده ان تبقى تركيا الى
جانبها الى اقصى حد بالنسبه الى موضوع حرب
روسيا في اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى ذلك هي
بحاجه الى تصويت تركيا على مستوى الناتو
لسه ما حبيت عضويه السويد وبالتالي تركيا
لديها اوراق ولكن تركيا ايضا بالمقابل هي
بحاجه الى امور من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وسوف تخاطر بها ومن بين اهم
النقاط هو طائرات المقاتله همم 16
بالاضافه الى التحديثات وقطع الغيار
للطائرات وهذا الامر قد ينتهي في حال
تركيا عمليه في سوريا
دكتور طارق غزله هذه الاوراق التي تشعر
تركي انها تمتلكها اليوم والتي قد تجعلها
دون ان تطلب اذنك كما سمعنا من الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان لا ينتظر اذن من احد ولكن ما
هي الانعكاسات وما هي ما هو حجم المخاطره
هنا
تركيا
بانها تود ان ترى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تساعد تركيا في قتلها للمجموعات
المنضويه تحت لواء حزب العمال الكردستاني
في سوريا تركيا والولايات المتحده خليفه
على مستوى حلف شمال الاطلسي ولكن نحن نرى
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تنحاز
الى تركيا في سياق القتال ضد حزب العمال
الكردستاني وهذا ما نظرت اليه السلطات
التركيه على انه خيانه من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لذلك اخذت تركيا
المبادره والمفارقه هي اننا نرى ان الدوله
الدوله
الاطلسي ولكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يبدو انها تتعاون في مرات متعدده مع
المجموعات المنضويه تحت لواء حزب العمال
الكردستاني في تلك المنطقه بشكل لا يؤخذ
لا بعين الاعتبار الاعتبارات الامنيه
التركيه هذا غير مفهوم من قبل الاتراك
لماذا يطلبون من تركيا هذه المطالب
الامريكيون هم من يتعين عليهم ان ياخذوا
هذه العلاقه بعين الاعتبار خصوصا بالنسبه
الى التحالف على مستوى الناتو وبالاضافه
الى ذلك انا اعرف ان روسيا لن تحاجي كثيرا
ضد هذه العمليه لان تركيا في
مسار الدولي ان حازت الى روسيا بعض الشيء
في ايطاليا الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا
وكانت تركيا تساعد روسيا للتخفيف من وطاه
العقوبات والحضري المفروض
ان ننتقل للسفير اندريه باكلانوف همم اذا
كانت تركيا ربما مطمئنه بعض الشيء لان
الاطراف الاخرى على راسها موسكو واشنطن لن
تتحرك ربما بشده في هذا الاطار ولكن نعرف
ان هناك اتصالات تمت بين موسكو وانقره هل
رشح الشيء بشان هذه الاتصالات فيما يتعلق
بهذا الموضوع تحديدا
اكثر
هذه العمليه العسكريه قد يكون لها اثر
كبير على العلاقات فيما بيننا
مهتمين جدا بالحفاظ على العلاقات التجاريه
الاقتصاديه هذا شيء مهم جدا وهي اساسيه
ونحن مهتمين بان كان فيك طريق
الاوروبي والعالمي ان يكون التعاون بيننا
وبين تركي شيء ثابت
ولكن قد تكون تركيا اخطات في حسابات هذه
العمليه ولم تحسب الى ما قد تؤدي اليه هذه
العمليات ليس هناك اي عمليات عدوانيه من
الاراضي السوريه ضد تركيا
ولكن اذا قامت بالهجوم قد تبدا هذه
العمليات فعلا وهذا قد يؤدي الى نتيجه
معاكسه تماما غير التي يتحدث عنها السيد
السفير او الدكتور قال المقوس طبعا الخوف
الامريكي التقليدي
تنظيم الدوله قد يستفيد من همم يعني
التوجه او ضرب تركيا في هذه في للمرحله هل
هو العامل المسيطر هنا ام هناك ربما
المخاوف بهذا الشان قد قلت ويمكن ان تدفع
واشنطن ان تتحلى عن حلفاء من جديد كما هو
الانطباع في المنطقه بانها تخلت عن حلفاء
اخرين في افغانستان وغيرها
تنظيم الدوله لا يزال حقيقيا وقيا وقائما
وقياده قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ووحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه قالت انه يتعين عليها
ان تعلق العمليات المناهضه لداعش لتجهيزا
وتحديرا للعمليه التركيه والشيكه هناك
نبعث قلق حقيقي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كما سبق واستلفت هناك الالاف من
المقاتلين التابعين لتنظيم الدوله في
سوريا باضافه الى عشرات الالاف من السجناء
واسرهم والذين لا يزالون في السجون وهذه
السجون تحت اداره كرديه في شمال شرق سوريا
وهناك خطرا كبير في سياق تركي في تفتح هذه
السجون ويخرج السجناء من تنظيم الدوله
بالاضافه الى ذلك بدات تركيا بعمليه قصفا
وحمله قصفا بعد الهجوم الارهابي الفضيه في
اسطنبول في نوفمبر وبعض القنابل سقطت
قريبا جدا من القوات الامريكيه وهذا قد
يؤدي الى ازمه كبيره بالنسبه الى علاقات
الثنائيه بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وتركيا في حال اصيب جنود امريكيون بسبب
هذه العمليه
وقطعتك هنا انتهى وقت الان مقفصكي همم
كبير البحث في قضايا الامن قومي الامريكي
من واشنطن اشكرك واشكر ضيفنا من موسكو
السفير اندري باكلانوف رئيس جمعيه
الدبلوماسيه واخيرا وليس اخرا الدكتور
طارق غوزلو عميد كليه العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه ايضا في اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لكم
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام
[موسيقى]